oh i'm loading me also loading my assets
how are we gonna know if there's if
we're we're in the new world
well there's supposedly new um things
you can build so maybe like our
blueprint list will change
maybe hey boom boom oh there i don't
know
what would be new would it be the
research thing would be new because
because you can only build what you can
what you've already researched yeah
oh at least wade's not moving like a
insane person again
bob are you seeing this about wade yeah
i don't know what's the deal with that
he put on the bear head and he changed
what are you saying i kind of missed
that wait is this the island we were at
yeah wait wasn't it bigger did we move
to a small
i think we moved to this remember
i have no recollection of this place
well let me look at the book
okay we got a net canister okay this
looks new backpack inventory expansion
oh thank god okay grass plot we need
dirt uh helmet we can make armor
the only thing i saw was that there's
like some kind of thing that
automatically gets water and fills up
the water now
oh yeah yeah i'm not if that's one of
the things we can build eventually
because my trees grew what remember how
my trees wouldn't grow
my trees grew yeah we do have trees
we've got like birch trees there's
different types
they weren't birch looking before no
they weren't birch they were birds all
right never mind oh yeah i remember this
oh my gosh the carpet i forgot about
the captain's nest it's the lush carpet
in the cabin
i remember this now oh i blocked you in
fantastic
and once again and you've got the you've
got the oh okay there he goes
apparently i'm hungry all of a sudden
i'm down here now everything's fine okay
do i get a hat what a hat do i get
where's my probably
the bucket oh i really hooked it at you
i'm sorry i got it
as a puppet that's not oh my god why
don't hold them by the teeth they're
sharp
that's what it means rows of those i
just see it in my bottom right like a
gun
like i've got a shark and i'm about to
shoot you with it
hey we got a seagull in our in the nest
oh
[ __ ] kill it no it's laying eggs oh
don't [ __ ] kill it then do we have to
do something about that yeah
no remember so the question is did we
explore
this particular island the last island i
remember exploring was one where we got
the
the honey and bees yeah this place is
way bigger than that was
or way smaller that was way bigger this
small just
no mark no size i know well do we want
to explore this island real quick like
yeah go go give it a scope i want to do
something about the organization of the
chess here because
it's i know it's hell at the moment i
remember that it just kept being hell
because someone whose name rhymes with
bade i've never done anything much less
used your system
oh i didn't use my system that's i'm
very aware wait wait how do we catch the
bees there's bees here again i don't
know what i did to catch them i think
you walk
up to the to the crouch and walk up to
it
and then left click it with like a sword
to catch the beast
you need a net unless you're just trying
to get them to get got by bees and then
yeah you use a sword yeah did i get them
i think you did i got it when you did
that jars there's a cooler over here
wait somebody's having
a kegger oh my god it was just full of
resources well they're mine now
you took the whole kegger or the whole
cooler check it right out
the whole kegerator i i'm not seeing
this
automatic water thingamabobber
can you tell what we need for that oh
wait no i do sprinkler we have one
yes sprinkler automatically waters your
crops i think he meant an auto water
purifier yeah oh i i have a funny
feeling maybe we
don't have the new update i'm not seeing
it in the research and frankly now i'm
remembering that we kind of had
some of this stuff are you saying that
we have to start over
i mean was a grass plot was that in the
old one
yeah i think so because i think that's
how you fed the animals the first thing
we can do is try to find a new island
uh because that would be the main thing
right like there's got to be
okay i've got a i've got a blip on the
radar oh we need the number that's right
we need to find the number
we had a number in the journal okay we
were on balboa island that's where we
were
oh jesus yeah all right
all right the bear you told me about
kind of forgot
it was here i hear him doing bear stuff
yeah he's uh barely attacking
oh [ __ ] i fell off a mountain i'll get
you you bear [ __ ]
oh i've got a blip for oh i got the new
island
it's 3 000 meters away jesus
beehive with flowers did we have this
before yeah i made that no
no i made that i remember that that's
adorable yeah it's so weird did you
paint the flowers on the beehive itself
uh yeah that was me and and i made this
bio fuel
uh reactor so that we can feel the
engines i do remember that because i
remember the
pipes yeah and i remember it being kind
of funny yeah it's it's a little funny
but it
i can i can just basically take raw food
and
uh i need to water how do you make a
sprinkler
this game is complicated i want to make
a sprinkler
[Laughter]
i don't like the laughing laughing such
a bad fake evil laugh
i mean fake i'm evil oh we did have
copper ingots okay we're good oh thank
god
can't believe the organizational
system's not working what are you making
exactly
um a sprinkler for the for the cross oh
right right right
yeah so i don't have to water the things
constantly
listen i'm basically just here to drive
the raft around so when you need to
drive
call raft driver bob do you guys want to
drive the raft to the other side of the
island there's a whole bunch of stuff in
the water on this side
raft driver bob sure okay if i'm aiming
this right
this should just goose water all over
this bad boy raf rider can you raise
the can you raise the anchor and turn
the engines on
drivers don't do that sort of stuff i'm
really more of a steerer this needs a
battery
oh yeah yeah there's supposedly a
battery recharging station too is that
something we can make well
no i'm fine i'll do it myself on the new
island what did he need bob
i got it no it's fine do we have a
battery anywhere
i don't know we we had to have one for
the um the
navigation system or whatever oh my god
but i think that was the only one we had
okay actually i can make a battery
that's not too bad
you can go whenever you want um how
how how how hitting the gas pedal i
don't know the anchor's down i think you
have to turn the engines on
oh my god wade you just killed a bear it
did reverse
do we know yes put them in put them in
reverse reverse they're not going
definitely not
go activate it right i got it turned
them on
oh okay there we go hey look at that so
smart
god it's been a while scrap anybody
scrap if i have scrap yeah i have some
can i have something you need it yeah i
need to make a battery for the sprinkler
get out of here i'm gonna truck it down
by the pewter thank you
there you go look at all this bear meat
and leather i guess i could cook it
do we need to continue to navigate
around this island weight or or
yeah you need to follow
god damn it okay yeah would you just
spill it with water
do what what do you mean empty the
navigation system was
uh the battery for the navigation was
empty you need to keep
turning the way we're turning well the
island is there so
and three five seven
i don't understand what the counting
means all right uh bob basically
straight through this island we got to
get around the island
all right we're going well this is great
that i'm driving the boat because i'm
also sort of eating lunch
that's great that is a good combo you
know back in back when i was a young lad
i used to go to the lake with my
grandparents and uh there were
definitely times where we would like
hold a sandwich in one hand the steering
wheel in the other oh
it's pollution what sploosh the
sprinkler
oh nice it works it watered everything
wow good do you have to refill the
sprinkler or is it just yeah yeah
yeah it's a big reservoir
we need to fill it up oh yeah probably
wait did you just leave the nav system
on market
yes and three two one
dead ahead overshot it a little bit
starboard is right port is left half
mast is how i woke up
all right now i'm on shark watch okay
yeah you just keep going straight ahead
we are way far away from it but
we are aye aye not captain it doesn't
seem to be getting any closer
are we going forward we're going the
right way we're going man
wait i'm not reading this right turn
left good good
yeah is this the way yep i'm looking at
it it is the right way
okay but you're not looking at it you're
downstairs
vital tasks but don't be snitching i'm
so utterly confused right now
i'm just gonna keep going this way
you're going the right way i think
are you sure mark's looking at it bob
looking at it i can see the machine
you know this right yes yes it's beneath
me
then why do you just say you are
hey there's a seagull doing something
yeah come here you bird thing got him
noon wait calm down
who's the new fisherman i don't know
someone should probably make food or
something though i mean i am currently
whoa did you guys just experience that
bagel
i made my noises for other reasons which
i'm not going to share with you
[Laughter]
full match the head up there bob like
jack sparrow i
might mysterious and confusing yeah
mostly confusing can we make another one
of these uh honeycomb
houses yeah do you have the bees for it
i don't know how many you need but i've
got
18 bees that sounds like enough look in
your uh
crafty menu thing it's a technical term
for it
i just dropped them in this storage
chest hey here's some kind of shark
thing happening i want me to do the
beast
[ __ ] damn bob what is that what did you
just use that cleaver
i got a sword that doesn't remember we
learned how to make a sword on that
island
oh i looked from the back i thought your
hammer was like three slices of tofu
stacked
like is that a new item wow
it's a skin bro just go on the store if
it's 7.99 or
3 000 zoinko coins
you can get a tofu hammer i gotta steal
my dad's credit card for zoink
kiddos if you're trying to get those
zoinko coins make sure you steal
that credit card uh do we have an axe of
some sort
i have an axe yeah because i think these
trees are ready to be chopped
chopping i think chocolate if you can
chop them they should be ready to be
chopped
chopped chop chop chop all right they
just exploded there was no seed
oh they just kind of mark you did it
wrong what do you mean i did it wrong
you did it wrong well i'm still going it
goes into your inventory check your
inventory see if you can i'm sorry
i'm only getting planks which is great
oh
yeah no yes oh i got a coconut from this
thing
that's a seed is that how seeds work
yeah i got one
cocoa nut that's not enough i had a
fishing pole i could fish oh i ate it i
ate the coke i'm sorry
mark i got confused with the hole in the
ground in my mouth i was that's
disappointing and stupid the coconut
mark oh my god we almost crashed into an
island but we didn't thanks to my
brilliant pilot experience oh wait we
might still
ah you're going
good you're good uh the skill
the raw talent that is legitimately the
tightest you could
hey wade how's that bee hive coming i
need to get six wooden planks i got you
pieces here
so many important take mine i have
harder longer plans what is the
organizational
system of this and why isn't it i didn't
fix it
it's in progress why is metal scraps the
most difficult thing to keep
stocked we have none we need to go well
there's an island right there there's
probably someone well i don't know we're
not
stopping all right well that might be
the root of the problem i don't want to
be
that guy but just a thought
well i realize that it's uh yeah it's uh
they're on the ground now they don't
float exactly i just
thought i just realized metal don't
float
i've got wait how many metal scraps do
you need i have 17 on me oh you have 17
can i have some i'm trying to make more
boxes so that we can have
a better organizational oh um
that's definitely insane trying to pick
it up i will
please don't leave me behind i'm taking
this shark uh coming back
how do we not leave you behind oh god
don't run me over
going forward all right okay good okay
great good stuff with the auto
the potatoes are almost grown again
potatoes grow like weeds in this [ __ ]
good more for the biofuel so do we need
to check our heading are we definitely
still good
oh worse oh mark's up there yeah i see
it right now it is
just amazing actually our headings i
don't i don't something about this
i don't believe you what no it's good
our heading is so good
why are all these beats over here by the
biofuel container we're working on it
okay this storage over by the biofuel is
for biofuel
inputables only the storage by the
smelter is going to be for
smeltables and planks i'm going to put
smeltables on the left
our planks are on the right huh are palm
leaves multiple i don't think so
because that's where i want to put my
palm leaves now that you said it out
loud well
but all right captain i have utter faith
in you
um should i go ahead and smell some
copper or do you want to smelt more
metal in good uh smell whatever you can
smell we
we should just smell everything we have
whoever smelt it
dealt it am i right am i right though
guys
until just now no just me
that's why i'm the captain wait what
have you done
what did i do how would you turn it that
way
i was trying to rotate it turns out
you're supposed to press r to
oh look you got blue on the left red on
the right everything about this is
exactly what you'd want
oh man i i could have rotated the blue
red and white i just wanted the black
and white to be the only color
uh but now that's oh hey this honey's
harvestable
so that's something that's something
everything's fine over by the honey
thing
about it you're right thank you
navigation your captain says
great job matey thank you
okay i dumped my water out instead of
drinking it
ah uh incoming
where are you incoming no brilliantly
piloted ship would never hit an island
such as this one uh all right i have
full faith in you captain
that's as well you should god i hate
these ladders do you guys ever hate
ladders with your entire being
yes god damn it specifically these
ladders these ladders man
they're not very good ladders oh it's
really hard to get up to the captain's
captain slight adjustment the brilliant
piloting continues
marvel at it as we don't slam into the
island
mark can't look right now he's at
navigation yeah mark has the navigation
lugging
it looks good here but then again i
don't have your eyes or your uh point of
view up there
or my dick i yeah oh shark's back
i don't see it oh there he is hey buddy
we're friends with him right yes his
name's
ted head you know ted the shark
wait was that it the island on the left
was that our location uh
i don't know uh you're on navigation
yeah navigator
uh the batteries are dead so i i didn't
turn it off
ah well battery's not my department not
my department
all right the battery battery liaison if
you could please
oh yes i need the three scrap please
uh uh no hats oh i believe our engines
are also
dodged oh dear we're dead in the water
are we oh goodness
uh it's okay we have okay hey honey i
got it
starting to remember some of our issues
from the past
issues that's what i always say
that is what he always what you've
always said why are there so many points
on the ground
you're god damn chode for one second
time
working on it what was the explosion the
engines are booted back up my dude
it was a [ __ ] explosion what was that
that was the engine's booting back up
oh right uh we're about to be out of
biofuel so
hard uh well hold on we got honey out
the ass
put get where where give let me let me
take here
i'll put it in this chest what does
honey look like those are honeycomb does
honeycomb
you need to make honey you have to craft
it in uh how do i do that honeycomb and
glass
there's glass eye working it's under the
little the little
resources what is the organization
we're working on where is the glass
it's done it's over here glasses are
right now it's over here
it's in uh this one this this one right
here
it's just for temperatures
sure i'm working on it i'm
working on it i like how you made flanks
chests
if we ever have extras of those well
it's go have more
gonna go eat and then i'll come back
down and i'll keep working on the
organizational system
we're probably overshooting what we are
if someone could make a battery
i'm working on it i'm working on it done
got a battery all right thank you
navigation oh back up
i see where we're going the blue icon is
the current
oh we need to turn left how far away
were we before was it 1600 or are we
further away
well we started at 3 000 so oh we're
making
terrible progress all right hang on
sending the tower
amazing ladders that are so good left
you said oh yeah
uh pretty much straight ahead here oh
okay that's not a very clear instruction
but i'll just go straight oh you did it
perfectly though
oh nailed it that's why i'm the cap
preserve this
battery i feel like that's the smart
play i agree with you good
sir hey the palm trees is growed mark
where's our and the potatoes is
growed you know guys
i am trying my best
i'm just gonna put it in here with the
honeycombs i feel like that's crazy
don't worry bob mark's on navigation
it's
it's funny when he pretends to be sad
no you're not sad you monster
yeah you got me one of it
the instant turn yeah yeah you got me
yeah yeah i didn't know how fast i was
going yeah
yeah uh either somebody with an axe or
somebody who knows about where's planks
is that
oh there's planks i knew that i put
those there all right thanks everybody
you're welcome bob should i be souping
the fish or cooking the fish
probably soup if we have the right kinds
of fish is more efficient
i'm gonna put some uh what do i have
here i've got mackerel tilapia and
herring i'm gonna put in
yeah i got pictures not names so i don't
really know about that
uh look forward
that's fine we're it looks like we're
gonna hit it dead on but i promise you
that's probably not gonna happen was was
your question
look forward i'm the captain of this
it's the frog
it's a frog it's the leaf it's a frog
don't just call it
the palm frog it's a frond just call it
leaf no
you just call it a glass of water to jug
a juice
because the words have meaning idiot
yeah exactly
i'm with bob on this one wait what
what how did that happen weighed some
kind of
wizard well now you got me i was trying
to conceal it but
you know all right fine i've been
casting spells this whole time
oh oh god scrap we need scrap
maybe we should go to that island first
crap yeah
you want to just slam those [ __ ] in
reverse or just turn them off that's
fine
oh are they out oh we out i mean we
could just
turn it away from it that's okay
well good news i changed direction
do you not know how this works this jug
right here
this jug pick that up and put it in the
big this thing
yeah no no no no no
no no means try something else no
yes but yes no
yes wade are you there's a yeah
i have a machete and you look like a
bear i put
it in i wonder what a jury of my peers
would think about this situation
hey look guys an even larger island in
front of us maybe we should have just
gone that way
now look in the distance off the off the
bow of the boat
the bow we'll probably need all of them
that's the front
all right i made it up okay i didn't
make it up
okay like i'm just trying to believe and
i'll believe whatever you say
the truth is out there
[Music]
nope hang on nope no i got this one hang
on
okay nope no that's not it
there it is are all of those together a
good
representation of me yeah okay
uh turn the engines off quickly quickly
why oh okay there we go look at this
lovely spinning motion we're in
let's go ahead and lobby here no
problems i'm doing fine i'm working
on the organization as hard as i can no
no mark's on navigation
yep mark if you're the one that's
responsible for this organization
i have some questions for you mark what
do you mean
france plastics
[Applause]
how did you do such an exemplary job
with so little resources and no support
from your friends
yeah i didn't have any i don't know man
i it was
tough every moment was a struggle but i
got through it
and what are you gonna do now that
you're a champion oh i
i mean finish the job you know see it
through to the end
are you just asking these to take a food
break so that you can
i mean i can eat and talk i'm i'm asking
these because i like you and i'm proud
of you okay
oh listen douchebag with an axe come
chalk some of these trees down oh
is that me yeah no no that's that's the
other dude well unless you have an axe
but you're not the dude
you're not the douchebag listen wait
wait wait that only leaves me
i can't be the douchebag i feel like
this time i'm just the lackey that gets
tossed around what mark i was just being
really nice to you
all right bob i had next the whole time
this do we literally stop at the only
island that doesn't have a
drop of scrap metal laying around it it
does well the scrap metal is usually in
the water and i don't see any in the
water so i think your observations would
be correct
all right yep you got there he got up
late now
those were the things the observations i
was basing my statement upon oh wait
there's scrap metal there's scrap metal
wait where yeah on the opposite side of
where our raft is that's good guys it's
good guys it's really good
not as good as your organization mark
can i just say
thank you can i just say yeah well
there's metal metal
are we low on metal or mark yeah get get
get everything yeah
oh i see the shark yeah we is that where
you are with
everything um cool okay next step i'm
going to try to get
i was burping in real life and the shark
attacked me that's horrible
hey guys i'm going to die wait hello
nice dodge i'm i'm uh dead you're dead
i didn't dodge i i didn't dodge either i
don't know what you saw but all i did
was swim
to the left and then his head it looked
like yeah he jumped out of there he got
me
oh hi i'm being carried by a good friend
all right poor douchebag
our old friend is about to die too get
out of the water my good friend
yeah yeah good friend good friend like
three seconds ago or
no no no put me in my bed that'll help
so i've got those i've got this metal
okay okay did you guys get more scrap
metal
a little bit but uh we need there's a
lot more we need to kill this yeah
should we drive around to the other side
so it's easier or that might be smart
let's do it okay oh my god look at the
organization
it's making progress it's just exploding
wait head broth that's a different
recipe i'm gonna take down the coconut
chicken recipe and i'm gonna put up head
broth it's good because we don't have a
lot of coconuts yeah we got a lot of
heads
and it needs a bucket of some white
liquid oh no
we know what head broth is now it could
be milk we probably need an animal to
make milk remember i told you there were
animals you could catch and people on
your boat
could be many things wait where are we
we went to the other side of the island
as discussed it's odd now it's off the
other side of the boat
yeah this is exactly what we discussed
and planned together
we're just a little bit further from the
island than i expected it's all yeah
well it didn't
look like we were this far away from it
when i was up on the captain's perch i
gotta be honest i might have been a
little
drunk but there's metal down here so
let's just
stop bickering and get you some oh god
oh god look out for what
this shark the shark we need to team up
on in murder
we should do that are you doing it
trying i got one hit
come on you you did i got him
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] i'm gonna die now don't
die again
nice hit mark me
or me oh no one's in there
no one is around me when do we get
automatic rifles to deal with the shark
yeah when do we get like military-grade
equipment
it's going after someone i don't know
right behind waden
i don't know what that laugh was i don't
want to
i appreciate you just going straight to
mocking instead of talking about it
we don't need to address anything about
what just happened we all know
why is this just called a head you'll
open it up
i don't know if we need two entire boxes
for heads
we got two types of heads what do you
mean
i'm glad we have something in each one
because if there was no net i'd break a
skateboard
i guess oh fishing fishing's fun fishing
yeah fishing watching oh great just
remember
fishing fishing yeah yeah yeah
why why are you saying oh my god that's
how i always talk uh-huh fishing
i love fishing that was really fun
fishing but i really like the piece well
i'm gonna step into the the wade's nest
and
rip one out is that what you call it
when you keep yeah
this next time we have waited in person
five years from now
it's like i was gonna go rip one out
boys goes into the bathroom
just here
isn't that how is that how you pee yeah
just everyone have fun okay bye
all right mark i got an inventory full
of stuff is your system ready
it's getting there depends on is it
ready for me where do i put clay
clay oh [ __ ] clay we're gonna put
flowers uh hanging flowers going head
clay will probably be knees uh where i
put shoulders
push shoulders is leather and like other
shoulder
type things what goes in raw raw's for
ore
are you okay you sound stressed okay
where does stones go
and stones on the other side of uh
fronds fronds and stones
okay all right niese's clay you said
jesus clay and other knee-looking type
things clay sand rope seaweed
all these to me that's not neat okay i
am so
ripped what oh
right you should really get your um
colon
checked out what's it prostate your
prostate's probably in your colon right
oh i don't think i have one of those
i think the shark is doing something
does that truck bigger wait am i crazy
that shirt bigger
squish i went in after him
uh no he's not you are an idiot if
that's what you asked okay
something about the naming system got a
little weird no no you just have to
you just have to understand and not be
an idiot yeah don't be an idiot
where's um these two and toes too
knees is plural both head shoulders
knees
knees and toes oh that's true well those
will have to be separate
yeah i'm getting to it wait it's working
progress sorry
toes is seeds and anything else that
looks like little toes
knees is blocky things that look like it
might be a knee
okay so that includes sand clay uh
vine goo it looks knee-like wait can you
help me with the shark
can you like yeah my weapon's about
shoot it with your gun or something
oh yeah we're under the thing
okay well i wasted all my health oh i
didn't get air i forgot the air part
about the getting air
that was why i was oh
you saw that you shouldn't have even
come close
i'm gonna make one bow go for it i'll
put the feathers are in head
where's the rope at is rope shoulder
rope
uh rope you can make from fronds but uh
rope is coming soon guys i am your
legolas
we have a flowers box uh yeah right now
actually
i'm gonna make these two plastics uh
probably like
flowers and happy things
what got me doing
it caught me too we're not feeling so
unsafe we're not safe here
mark i've i'm going to uh up to my
captain's hidey hole
okay are we in a good spot to get metal
yeah there's some metal down there we
can get rid of this
dang shark okay oh he's gonna die soon
he's gonna die he's gonna die painful
all right yes he's dead yeah he's dead
okay time to go for metal
yes yes
we need so much metal i have a weird
confession to make
i i couldn't hold this in anymore though
i wanted to um
so when the shark attacked you both he
came for me but i got back on the raft
at the last second and i was hoping to
stab
him and then i think he was just stuck
in the full murder animation and he
somehow got you guys
so i think it was my fault i'll never
forgive you
i feel good about coming clean don't
really feel bad about what happened to
you but i came clean so
my conscience is clear i can go to hell
peacefully now no you go to hell and you
die
in which order that order good you go to
the hell and you die
you guys got this i'm going to keep
working on the organization my hook's
about to break actually
i kind of don't have this literally my
hook just broke and there's metal right
in front of me
i can give you my hook if you come up
and i'll give it to you
did you register my side did that land
for you
oh i forgot air and my hook's broken can
i have your hook too oh
wait a minute come on
is that you bob okay thank you wouldn't
want wade to have that
the hell that's the sound of me drowning
is that not what you sound like when you
drown not when i drown i don't know
about wade
oh that's exactly what i saw when i
drown drowning again
oh no i gotta keep breathing constantly
[ __ ] oh god i'm gonna do the grossest
thing i can imagine and eat food while
i'm swimming in salt water
everybody loves ocean seasoned ah the
shark is back
oh no i'm out of health because of all
the drowning
wait friends wait
wait a minute i didn't understand how
drowning works okay that's unfortunate
oh hey bob i guess i'm fine i'm back now
there's more stuff out there
there's a shark out there though we
could kill it you and me
and mark no i'm good i got
organizational business
you and me and us you and me and our
army
who did a bird take my flowers
oh we're out here living and dying
that are on a razor's edge and you are
gardening
and what's going to happen when you oh
when you cut when you come home
and you don't see flowers and you don't
get happy what are you gonna do
you're right if i don't have a fresh cut
bouquet on the table and i get home from
work next to my martini new york time
slippers pipe
and smoking jacket or whatever people
wear in this imaginary world i'm
doing a joke about yeah i will be
outraged
uh-huh not to change the subject mark
i'm a little curious why you have raw
and head next to each other
raw's on the other side of head do they
have nothing to do with each other
okay yeah i don't know what connection
you're making here and you're messed up
brain wave but yeah it's fine
uh well if you're gonna no there's no
one
go on go on
go you gotta have your head cooked man
you can't do it wrong
i'm what oh oh [ __ ] hey can you
grab me oh don't bite me don't bite me
don't bite me lay me gently in the bed i
appreciate there you go buddy
sleep tight oh this is sweet
oh you're done hey oh yeah i'm okay oh
i'm sorry did you want to watch me
wait wait i'm not there i'm not there
i'm not there oh oh
that's so sweet right by the bees
he died got it all right we can go
harvest some more
i can get my arrows back from him too
they stay in his corpse
oh i shouldn't have harvest morning yeah
sorry i should have finished harvesting
the corpse
all right let's get all that metal stuff
mark are you done yet
jeez
almost i'm sorry i didn't mean to okay
it's uh it's okay
rationalize the feelings of hurt and
pain that were deep inside my soul but
i'm good i'm good now
okay then i'm not sorry oh okay that's
fair oh the drowning i always forget
about the drowning
it makes you feel it but i've never met
a person who uh who had drowned to death
that kind of does make me feel better
actually i wouldn't want to meet
someone that drowned to death why sounds
very scary because mark is closed-minded
that's why that sounds very presumptuous
mark i'm sure they're fine people
try to have the open mind no could at
least try more
no okay that's a very convincing
agreement
oh you've got me there no is there
something going on that we need to know
about over there
okay no can we make the swimming gear
isn't there like flippies and oxygen
tanks and stuff we could be making to
make this all oh
yeah totally better yeah yeah
my brain is just broke my brain what
it's not a complicated thing i'm trying
to think of what's cookable and what's
not
cookable but my brain is really
struggling right now i don't know why
why are you trying to think of what's
cookable and not cookable
i'm making a cook chest and eat chest
and
my i can't rationalize anything
oh well why don't you just say him out
loud we'll help you figure it out
okay cooking we don't have a fingers
chest and i need
seaweed isn't quite knees like the goo
see we would be toast
obviously seaweed is fronds no no see
with his toes
it's fronds it's not toes it's toes kind
of toes look like a seaweed
my toes look like a seaweed well your
toes are weird then
oh i broke the hook that you gave me
well now my present's gone i'll never
remember mark for the rest of my life
what about extra rope where can i put
rope clearly ah the shark's back
yeah oh i understand why that was
confusing but those statements
were kind of unrelated
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] wayne why are you doing that
oh i just
stumbled upon the crowd what's up
standing in front of a chest just
talking [ __ ] on the ground
i wasn't i was mass correct
my systems it's fine whatever
just [ __ ] all over my dreams mark
i'm here for your system buddy don't
worry about it i just need to know where
the rope goes
hey mark there's a seagull really going
to town on your flowers
cars they're our fires your stupid
flowers that you love so much are in
peril
do you want biofuel do you want that do
you want me to rub honey on your
shoulders do you want that
then you that same thing they are the
same thing
do you guys not like my organizational
system my work
i love it a1 2b
watermelon three that joke from fall
guys i
love it i'm here for your system
thanks man thank you always a sport
nobody in the comments likes it
because they're all ignorant stupid
heads i
like it i love the system i'm in i'm on
the
sand would be raw that's a good point
yes but clay that surprises you it's
disappointing still
the knees so i'm gonna put but clay
is oh wait no clay is nice clay you
gotta lay out
yeah we're both stupid for different
reasons oh why is it raw
why is that raw the shark meat i didn't
cook
did you just shove shark meat in your
mouth no no i put it on the
on the stove top grill can you stop
using my stoves without my
permission i thought you were captaining
are you cooking yeah
captain of the ship where the stoves are
sorry i'm
captain of the whole world as far as
you're concerned
mark's the organizer you're the captain
cook i just need to find my place on
this ship you know i'm just trying to
find my place you're the best boy i'm
pretty sure that's a roll on a ship
there's also shark bait
[Music]
it's a good movie all right uh we're on
anchoring i'm
activating the engines okay heading
check
navigator mark are we going the right
way
yep remember that thing about pouring
the water out instead of drinking it
yeah yeah kind of vaguely now don't do
that
okay weird uncle who i didn't invite to
this party
don't do that do we ever cook vegetable
soup
that's what i had been cooking but i
don't know if we want to use the
potatoes for biofuel i don't know if
that's the best thing i think we might
need to cook fish
what i might do is i might set up
another crop plot just for
potatoes that need we can have a biofuel
crop yeah i'm thinking just separating
and then these can actually be beets and
potatoes yeah so this will be beets
so i'll replant this beets and taters
yeah i'm gonna take uh
summers uh i'll leave the beets it'll
just be potatoes for uh
the biofuel okay yes lord of the rings
exists thank you
why is why is there who put a chest back
here
by the secrets secret chest this is a
secret
why is it back here secret yes
i'm actually having a fantastic time
organizing i didn't think this would be
fun
are you a fan of consolidation would you
say
not usually which is the thing i usually
yeah you got really mad at me when i did
that
well now we know what 2021 markiplier's
gonna be into
dude i hope so my life is chaos if i
have some organization in my life i'll
be so happy
you do look at all these chests this is
some organization you've succeeded in
your goals for next year already
thank you that was both a complimentary
and patronizing
impressive thank you thank you
i succeeded in my goals for 2021.
my goals were just to get a good
old-fashioned compliment from my friends
did it have to be sincere no i take what
i can get
okay man well i'm glad you have
realistic expectations
i can't believe i remembered where
vinegar was literally my brain
it looks like a knee head obviously
i know this too about that
[Music]
what the hell
[Laughter]
what the hell what the hell was that
then i opened the first chest and the
fronds weren't where i thought they were
going to be
so i turned into like my great grandpas
what the hell i'm sorry
grandpa wade i'm so sorry
for whatever i did please don't get your
belt
that's already got oh that's not even
the same voice
you'd better watch out you're going and
i already didn't got my belt
no weird family win ever tell you that
yeah i'm going to do some more fishing
how have we not gotten to this island oh
i i think i see it
as you say that i just have an infinite
stack of potatoes in my hand and i kind
of don't want to put it down
wait mark you're on navigation right
because i haven't looked in a while now
yeah
where's the navigator mark yeah we're
headed the right way
hey guys i think the water guy is empty
uh so the island is the battery dead
it's not water might be dead batter
might be dead it doesn't need battery we
gotta get that battery charger
holy biscuits assuming we have to
restart to get it
hopefully we're close to it no i think
there's recipes
blueprints that we can pick up off the
ground so i'm pretty sure that it's just
something we gotta find
okay well this is definitely a place i
see pads
on the right actually check the
navigation yeah yeah this is it
okay oh did you i did i wasn't i
actually i saw
you when you said yes we're standing
right behind me so i was like i'll go
actually look look at this it's like
civilization up there
wow wow there's ah building other
bridges
oh wait you're right i thought you were
just bullshitting
wow what if i ever bullshitted you every
time
blessed you are you allergic does a
sneeze or a scarf
or both man cause if it was just a
sneeze it was brilliantly timed can i
tell you
it was just a sneeze i have no weapons
i have two weapons you can't have any
all right
oh by the way we're going right for the
wall yeah i'm up here captaining don't
worry about it
turn the engines off we're parked baby
uh mark i hope you're by the engines
huh wait did you what stop
stop whoops whoops that does not sound
healthy
i i couldn't i could never tell which
way is on and off so i
the whole i'm glad you were there to see
that yeah we're off we're good
we turned it off and i watched bob turn
it on off on off
off it's fine it's fine he's the captain
he knows what he's doing don't
question the captain no of course no of
course not
spray
now you're whatever word you're thinking
it's cutting out
it's sprayed is that good yeah because
now the potato downstairs are cooking
and it's got a water thing by it so it
can get water it's uh
we are in business hell yeah
i found a new note for you guys oh cool
dude there's a bicycle schlong machine i
don't know what it does
i'm sorry um wait a moment what
hang on one of those words i would like
an
explanation sir where are you guys are
you on the boat
yeah yeah come i to papa i definitely
don't want to do that yeah this doesn't
sound
can i just stay here where i am i don't
want to learn what a bicycle
machine is what hit me sounds like
somebody's getting what they deserved i
didn't bring any food with me
did you arrow me i was in the water no i
did not arrow you you
look look nothing about this oh
actually actually okay
okay it takes a minute but yeah okay
okay
this is a bicycle
wait there's a tear deck falcon
what is that what oh my god is that
what's actually hitting this is there's
something incredible on this island that
i should pay attention to because i'm
getting a little organization
tactile monster near the bicycle swamp
worth me stopping organizing
is it worth you should you should check
it out you should keep this
mark
[Music]
oh this is terrifying i hate it
i don't know if we want these pigs
they're not very friendly how
did this happen to me who put
beets and watermelon seeds in ingots
i'm breaking everything i'm gonna break
everything
[Music]
you